uno de los incidentes de tráfico de
personas más mortíferos en la frontera
entre eeuu y méxico el lunes de las
afueras de la ciudad de san antonio en
texas un grupo de emigrantes fue hallado
dentro de un camión la mayoría de ellos
muertos el hecho ha sido calificado de
horroroso por el alcalde de san antonio
es trágico saber que 46 individuos ya no
están con nosotros que tenían familias
que buscaban una vida mejor y ahora
tenemos 16 personas luchando por sus
vidas en el hospital nuestra prioridad
en este momento es llevarles toda la
ayuda que podamos pero esto no es nada
menos que una terrible tragedia humana
los que fueron trasladados al hospital
se encuentran en condición estable pero
sufren las consecuencias del calor
extremo en texas las temperaturas
alcanzaron los 39 grados
los pacientes que vimos sufrían de calor
y de agotamiento no hay señales de que
había aire acondicionado en el vehículo
no se ha confirmado la nacionalidad de
los migrantes hasta el momento mientras
una investigación federal está en marcha
con tres sospechosos bajo custodia